i believe the last time that we spoke to
you was right before you gave birth to
your son grayson so how is life going
let me tell you i
at first it was really hard like people
do not talk about the fourth trimester
but now that i've gotten through that
he's seven months now
that's crazy and he is crawling i have
to have a helmet on him so he doesn't
bump his head it's just amazing it's
amazing oh i love that okay so be honest
who do you think is better at changing
diapers you're your hubby
i have okay i hate to admit this but
initially my husband was way better at
changing diapers to me i know i know
what do you mean like he took more
initiative or he just he was just better
at changing the poop diapers like that
is just
too much you're just not prepared for
something so cute to be that
smell that bad it's so bad
that's so good well hey that's not
always the case with husbands so i think
that i know awesome you have a keeper
i'm very lucky he has been an incredible
baby daddy for sure
okay so when it comes to the best baby
gifts i mean listen i know you don't
want to pick favorite but would you say
carrie underwood's baby gift was maybe
the best
hands down and that is actually one of
his favorites is that piano it was
it came right on time in a time that was
really hard for me and just to watch him
light up when he was playing the piano
was just
too much did you know she was gonna give
you a gift or was that like a complete
surprise i had no idea there were so
many people that i was so surprised like
little big town got him something
so did chrissy metz and like kelly
bannon a lot of like i know i'm like
this baby is way more loved than i was
when i was a baby
amazing so is it last question is it um
in terms of obviously the baby gifts is
it a blessing or a curse that carrie got
this piano like it's it's great to hear
the music but sometimes are you like
turn it off
i'm like oh god please don't do music
but he's and he really loves it so it's
like both it's a blessing to watch him
so happy but then it's like oh god
don't do it grayson don't yeah do it
have you ever thought about doing a
collab with carrie and your son because
i would just be adorable
like that would be like a dream come
true just to watch her hold my baby
would just be enough for me oh i love
that um if he ever wanted to get into
the music industry obviously you've seen
the ins and outs the highs and lows
would you be supportive of his choice
i would be supportive of any choice as
long as it's in the good side of things
like but whatever he wants to do in his
life that will make him happy i will
support it
oh such a good mom all right let's talk
about all this new music this is so
exciting for your fans your new album
remember her name you know you have said
that this is essentially a closing of a
chapter what do you mean by that
i mean it's because i've been making
this album for a very long time
and
there's so many songs lessons love
everything that i learned within a 10
year span is in this album and i want to
move past that now
and start
you know
my second project you know and this is a
closing of that chapter there's so much
that happened in 2020
and past that that we've learned and i'm
just closing that and ready for new
lessons yeah and what would you say is
the kind of journey that listeners will
go on when they listen to remember her
name
you're gonna go on a
there's
literally a song for everyone and you're
i feel like at the end that will be
i hope people walk away feeling hopeful
it's a journey there's lessons you will
laugh you will cry
you will
there's bops in there too you're going
to feel you're going to want to dance
you're going to have all of that and i
just think it's going to be an
incredibly emotionally amazing journey
oh i love that now you co-wrote 15 of
the 16 songs on this album and that is
that is so
personal how vulnerable do you get in
this
you know i wrote this album and i can't
i have want to credit the amazing
songwriters that i wrote this with but
they're some of my closest friends
they're people that i've really
grown to love so
it was very easy to to go there
because they were my friends and and
we were willing to dig down dig deep to
do that and it's just
it's awesome yeah i feel like you are
such an inspiration not only as an
artist in your music um people who
follow you on social media what kind of
response do you get specifically from
women
you know women
i'm a girls girl
through and through like that is where
i'm at i love women i think women are
such incredible
like god knew what he was doing when he
made women and um the responses i get a
lot of women just feel seen like no
matter who they are who they love
they feel seen and they feel like
somebody understands them and that was
my whole purpose so yeah it's really
cool to feel that when you put out a
song like love my hair what kind of
reaction do you get from listeners
you know
i've gotten such a cr um
a unanimous support around this song and
it's been really cool it speaks to so
many people
because
our hair is so important
to our existence whether you have coily
hair like mine whether you wear lace
front wigs like i do whether you wear
your hair in braids like they're all a
part of us and so often people don't
realize the power of their words
and
what you can say about someone in their
hair
can really be damaging and so i hope
this brings light to that
yeah oh no it absolutely does it's such
a good song um when you think of you
know you obviously talked about this out
in the last 10 years but in the last
year year and a half for so many people
the highs and lows people are still
trying to figure out and process this
past year
what has this past year been like for
you this past year
there's been a silver lining it's been
hard but i'm also an introvert like
people i'm like an introvert extrovert
and i actually really love being inside
so that has been great i've also got to
start a family which is something that i
really
i never thought was a possibility for me
and so
it's been
challenging but it's also been really
amazing to be able to spend time with my
family and create music in my home
yeah
you know when i think back on the
grammys i know that was months ago but
does that still feel surreal to you
it feels so it's
i still don't believe that that happened
i still can't believe that like i had
given birth a month
before that performance you would never
know
oh oh the the spanx and everything that
i
had to wear to fit into that dress like
it was a lot and i'm just still so
grateful for that moment but nothing
tops my baby tops at all
right absolutely and that makes sense
that makes sense but when you're at the
grammys did you run into anyone that you
were just completely star struck by
no because it was all because of covid
right
like i didn't even get to i mean i got
to see john mayer which is really cool
like when i was
standing on my side and to know i was
singing in front of john mayer that was
a little nerve-wracking and so that's
cool
but i tried to keep my cool like of
course you know but i was i was pretty
freaked out yeah no you just freak out
in your hotel room after not yes that's
basically what i did
you know when you think of artists that
you've worked with that you've written
with who is on your bucket list to do a
collaboration with who would just you
know be icing on the cake for you
i would love to um
do something with carrie underwood
um i just love her
i think she's such a powerful woman i'd
also like to do something with dolly oh
i still think she's just so iconic and
amazing
yeah
and she's so entertaining in every
interview she does like she's still such
a um like such a great role model for so
many people too yeah and you know who
else like i
have a really
building a really cool relationship with
is miley cyrus like i really enjoyed
performing with her
and her stand with you um show that she
did for paramount plus
and i just
she's also someone that i would think
would be awesome to sing with
yeah i could see that listen miley dolly
you
can we make this happen can we make this
happen yeah so when you you know when
you're performing with miley like what's
she like
you know i
i haven't spent that much time with her
but i'm building something with her she
is incredibly kind yeah and very real
and everything that she says in
interviews like she does not like fake
like she really does not like fake
yeah like don't kiss up to her like be a
real human and i respect that
yeah i feel like not enough people are
like that you know
like no matter what you do you're still
a human being and i just love that that
miley sticks to that
yeah thank you too i love hearing that
that's pretty awesome thanks for sharing
that okay now you've been nominated for
new artist of the year at the cma awards
how cool is that
you know it's so crazy because i've been
at this for 10 years so i'm not exactly
a new artist but i'm
you know there's that but i am really
really grateful for that you know i've
been trying so hard and to finally get
that recognition is really cool and then
when you found out you're nominated
against
ha have you processed that these are
fantastic artists just like you're
saying they're all you know it's a very
very competitive
new artist category and
it's
it's an honor to be a part of that like
i like the challenge i think that that's
really cool to be there with so many
talented people yeah i'm not saying pick
your favorite but when you're reading
the list of who's nominated or you know
when you're listening to it was there
one artist that stood up that you're
like oh damn
yeah yeah um definitely i think ingrid
andrews
is one that i was like damn because i
just think she's such an incredible
songwriter her project that she put out
was incredible she's just
so good like that's one and gabby
barrett she's also a great vocalist like
that's a very tough
category to be in yeah absolutely well
you should go i mean listen i'm not
surprised but yeah what a what a great
year for that category and such great
talent yourself
do you
do well preparing for award shows are
you a last-minute person do you i am not
wearing
no i am not a last-minute person even
though they try to do things last minute
which drives me crazy but i you know
when it comes to award shows especially
performances yeah i really take those
seriously and i get a movement coach and
i get someone to
because you have them
like this is a moment
and i think it's really important for
you to put your best foot forward in
that and really try everything you can
to reach those people behind the camera
yeah
do you write a speech beforehand just in
case if you're nominated no
i don't know i i guess it's i don't know
i i'm just
i don't know i think a part of me is
like oh there's no way i'll win so why
make a speech so maybe there's that but
i don't know
that's awesome so you've just you know
this year there's so much to celebrate
um what does the rest of this year look
like for you
the rest of this year looks really busy
there's a lot of shows award shows and
and
concerts that i'll be doing as well as
being a mom
i'm trying to figure out how to do all
of that at the same time but putting up
this album is just
and watching people react to it i think
will be my most exciting thing to do
that's amazing is there someone that you
allow listen to your music before you
put it out that you know will be 100
honest with you
yes i yeah i sent stuff to um a woman
her name is reecey palmer
she's the reason why i'm here she's
another um black country singer
and
her approval is is really important for
me and so i sent it to her
yeah you know you said something too
that this is a this is kind of a closing
chapter in this new chapter how do you
see yourself
you know with who you were to who you
are now
man who i was
then i was so uncertain and i was so
just trying to please people yeah and in
doing that i would i did it did such a
disservice to me
and my heart and now i'm just
trying to be
unapologetically me and i i
that is the difference and it's it's
freeing it's so exciting